[Música]
vamos falar agora da água não falar da
água e do futuro problemas e discussões
eu tenho alguns exemplos pois gostava
ter uma idéia de quem está na sala
podiam levantar o braço quem for do
porto
não estou a falar do jogo de amanhã
alguém se lembra de ter te falta d'água
em casa nos últimos anos
alguém se lembra da última cheia do
douro
também vamos falar disso não está a
funcionar o meu eu vou pedir desculpa
treino virar de vez em quando não tem
outra alternativa
há cerca de 20 anos faltava água no
porto
imaginem que chegavam a casa não tinha
água e que não tinham água durante dias
e não sabiam quando ela vinha
este ano uma seca tremenda a água só
faltou em viseu cidade do cabo uma das
cidades mais ricas da áfrica pessoas a
fazerem fila para obter uma pequena
quantidade da água por dia
as zonas no mundo onde toda a gente
gasta horas do seu tempo do seu dia para
procurar mais magra no magma quantidade
da água provar para a família 2010
cheias na madeira 50 pessoas casas
construídas sobre o haiti que já ia vai
água e inundou destruiu matou 2004
indonésia tsunamis
250 mil mortos curiosamente depois da
construção
tal como no caso da madeira também em
parte voltaram a construir as casas no
mesmo sítio pode acontecer outra vez tem
um bom time também
enquanto nós temos aqui a população do
mundo está a aumentar
somos 7 bilhões de milhares de milhões
não é bilhões em milhares de milhões de
fazer mais correta está a aumentar a
população enquanto estamos aqui está
infelizmente também aumentará o número
de pessoas que não têm água em casa não
conseguimos fazer com que a
infraestrutura creche ao rito que
gostariam 80% da população vive em
países em desenvolvimento em países mais
parecido com o nosso com a maior parte
da população do estado tanto em portugal
como no mundo rural para a urbana onde
vai encontrar cidades que não estão
preparadas para o sistema em
organizações informais sem água sem
saneamento em ruas asfaltadas
somos tais 753 bilhões
a onu diz podemos ser mais ou menos os
mesmos dentro dentro de até 2100 ou
podemos ser mais um louco faz toda a
diferença
a terra dificilmente com portaria hoje
os 7,3 bilhões a consumir com nós
consumimos imagina e poodle imagining
costa o problema da água
quais seriam os outros problemas também
aprendemos todos na escola que a água é
um bem escasso como faço nesse caso
temos acesso a uma pequena quantidade
menos de 1% é quantidade de água que
temos
é quase toda a outra está com essa
jogada
o estágio avançado o estado demasiado
fundo está inacessível
infelizmente não é bem assim como vamos
ver caso contrário não queremos cá todos
e nem pensar nos nomes de seis milhões
que mesmo patamar cultas
neste contexto o que é que nós podemos
fazer
em primeiro lugar temos a noção que uma
torneira aberta gasta cerca de 10 litros
minuto lúcio nosso amanhã
estamos a falar de cinco minutos pra mim
em dois minutos tem cabelo curto
quem tiver o cabelo mais comprido tenha
um ser mais tempo cinco minutos cada um
nós gasta cerca de 100 litros de água
por dia saem 150 apartamentos muito
também do cabelo para quem gasta 100 e
150 ainda precisa ficar com o cabelo
bonito não tem nenhuma razão para se
sentir culpado nós temos infraestrutura
para isso eu só quem gasta 400 e 500
litros e tem que começar a sentir
culpado mesmo assim se conseguirem
poupar um bocadinho vale a pena levar o
cara
gastamos 300 litros d'água para o carro
três leitos d'água por esconder
há cerca de três dias de consumo médio
de uma pessoa
o debute as perdas entre os temas
públicos nas câmeras perdem entre 30 e
80 por cento integrava enquanto cidadãos
são dados públicos temos que exigir que
o nosso sistema do google tenha níveis
perdas mundo deveria sair certamente
abaixo de 5% 10% e 15% enquanto cidadãos
temos que ver se pega
estamos fartos de ver jogar assim parte
dessa água não chega a lado nenhum não
vai chegar lá nenhum erro horas não vai
chegar à escola
é fácil é possível jogar de outra
maneira
a agricultura de precisão é rega
gota-a-gota gasta muito menos produz
muito mais
podemos construir barragens não é fácil
hospital ea o que leva à barragem
permite transferir água do inverno do
verão emperram essencial dos peidos dos
anos comidos provas anos secos é
controverso
se eu perguntasse quem é favor da
barragem do contra não vou fazer mas há
muita gente acha que uma barragem
destrói paisagisticamente um rio tem
conveniente do ponto de vista da
biodiversidade tem conveniente do ponto
de vista de navegação mas também pode
ter vantagens construir uma nova
barragem são precisos 10 20 anos de cada
10 tentativas de ganhar se a uma ou duas
não é tudo mas quanto mais melhor do
bairro vai não tinha água era zero até
passar e quando passou a ter dinheiro e
nem sequer é petróleo começava o
dinheiro do petróleo passaram a ter toda
a água quiser fumar perto energia barata
muito dinheiro utilizado tem uma pista
de esqui melhor que a nossa
isto é num centro comercial
são paulo atual dois mundos ao lado do
outro
do lado direito não falta nada do
material
do lado esquerdo falta muita coisa
curiosamente quem está do lado esquerdo
tem água paga pela água dez vezes mais
do que pagam os do lado direito da rua
que podemos fazer do nosso mudar a dieta
não têm a noção eu também não tinha um
tio de carne de vaca
basta 15 mil litros d'água por ser
produzidos 150 dias de consumo uma
pessoa um simples bife 3 mil litros
o hambúrguer 2.500 um frango um terço
continuar mas continua a ser muito
milito uma simples salada três dias de
consumo
mudar a dieta faz a diferença toda feliz
mesmo a nível mundial já consumindo mais
peixes ea cultura do que se produz
isso é bom gasta menos água mais
saudável também podemos organizar o que
é isso é transformar a água do mar em
água doce como é que funciona vai ficar
2 litros da água do mar a aproveitar se
um litro de água doce volta um litro de
água com o dobro do sal tomate tem
alguns inconvenientes mas são os silvas
custa 50 cêntimos o metro cúbico uma
família passar a beber água doce
utilizada em casa para ter água
deionizada em casa não tinha água outra
forma seria pagar mais cinco euros por
mês é a diferença entre não ter água e
ter água é dinheiro é que não são 50 e
500 15 espanhol jamil salmi
organizadoras persona está em seu
organizador londres tem de ser mediadora
admiradores e organizou sobre o quarto
vários sítios onde o pico turista que
chega não é preciso fazer um sistema
para igual para todo o ano da
agricultura no meio do deserto da
austrália
coisa que não falta é deserto que se há
coisa que não falta 10 pessoal e
instalação de suar com essa energia
solar vai buscar água marcha organizam
os produtos em que o caso tomada pode
ser a solução uma grande solução para
alimentação no mundo quando houver muita
gente fazer agricultura num certo
utilizar a água
atualmente o que fazemos é coisa menos
indulgente que a vamos buscar água em
por rios como suja é baixo
pois a outra cidade que fazer a mesma
coisa que vai captar onde nós deixarmos
não é preciso fazer assim os astronautas
quando foram à lua não farão água por um
tempo todo usaram sempre a mesma
podemos fazer a mesma coisa nas nossas
cidades nas nossas casas na nossa casa
usamos a mesma água prever protocolista
e pregar não faz muito sentido podemos
reutilizar a água em casa em casa o doce
da manhã pode servir para lavar a roupa
vai aproveitar essa água e calor poupa
energia
bill gates deu voz a um sistema entra
santíssimo transformação de esgoto em
água eo pior aqui o que eu estava
fazendo faria também está a beber água e
esgoto cinco minutos antes e tem todo o
dinheiro do mundo conseguiu fazer isso
fazem isso na nba há 50 anos como
resultado em cingapura
praticamente toda a água vai ser
customizado a bicicletas podem produzir
água doce a partir da água salgada ou
água limpa a partir da água suja exemplo
um país em desenvolvimento é possível
buscar água as nuvens mas com o leão com
sais de prata com saulo tem problemas
ambientais e problemas com isso
matrix é uma possibilidade de caraguá
temos de umidificadores é possível
buscar água ao ar com um identificador e
produzir água não façam isso em casa não
bebam água do significado dor precisam
ter um tratamento adicional
agora todo mundo dentro da lógica do
tempo natural versus oficial temos o rio
douro como era antes para que deus e do
rigor com agora possam sustentar as
barragens onde havia barcos do barco a
deus agora os barcos do mar a freira
cruzeiro
gosto mais dos primeiros outros mundos
não vou perguntar a alguns viram uma
coisa outro dia
outra daqui a alguns anos aquela
barragem não vai ser precisa incluir
aquela barragem não sei precisa produzir
energia elétrica por estar a produzir
por um número qualquer
voltamos aos barcos rabelos é isso que
as pessoas querem pergunta diferença
natural e artificial
achei no douro esta deve ter sido por
volta de 2001
nós temos funções pachedo do que isso
porque quando achei a água entra
naquelas que os estabelecimentos que
havia antes até nome ser mais do lado do
porto um cartaz como membro não encontra
problemas não consegui servir em finos
até águas da puzzle quer dizer que as
cheias no porto são previsíveis
contrariamente a outras ainda bairro
no entanto causou prejuízos não era
necessária uma solução palerma cheias do
governo ia com ongs feita por um
engenheiro seria em 1886 a água nunca
chegou ao topo é inferior se é assim
então tem solução
fazemos um muro dos dois lados do rio a
mesma cota ea água nunca chega outro
lado nós não é e não é brilhante
[Aplausos]
para finalizar temos elenco junto
problemas
a população vai duplicar o neo energia
vai ficar dez vezes mais barata ou dez
vezes mais cara
não sabemos alterações climáticas vai
haver ou não depende da população
depende de outras coisas nível do mar
pode subir 23 metros subir 23 metros que
as inundações né na foto temos a costa
nova com problemas temos a flórida miami
com a 6 milhões e milhões de pessoas
eventualmente donald trump vai ter que
ser levado ao rancho e vi que seria
irônico que eu sei se por causa das
alterações climáticas em que não
acredita em dinheiro e mais ricos que
outros podem ver ou não distribuição
ambiente vai ver mais ou menos a
terceirização não sabemos
todas essas decisões são políticas água
é um assunto político
são estes os melhores que outros
os próximos talvez sejam piores
e há uma coisa que os políticos nem
sempre fazem cumprir o que fazem cumprir
por inteiro
em portugal ainda não se ganham ou
perdem eleições por causa do ambiente no
país 5
temos que fazer alguma coisa nesse
sentido porque para resolver problemas
com este grau de incerteza temos que ter
o espírito garrett mcnamara 2013 a ser
faro está em equilíbrio instável com
imensa preocupação ao momento presente
não cai
estraga tudo mas por outro lado tem que
estar de olho no futuro para ir quando é
preciso
é assim que temos que decidir enquanto
pessoas cidadão enquanto técnico do
setor da água enquanto políticos com
decisão neste setor
dimitar um gato
o gato é um bicho de perto eu acho que
estava à espera do momento certo para
dar um salto quando for o momento
salta para a esquerda salta para a
direita com esta incerteza é que o
podemos fazer o aterramento o futuro e
por respeito à água
a mensagem final posso dar é uma
mensagem de esperança
tecnicamente os problemas que temos tido
poderíamos temos evitado se tivéssemos
feito algumas das coisas que foram
feridas
o futuro blog fraco mas se tivermos
estas esses princípios
tecnicamente também se em virtualmente
mudar os comportamentos e se exigir um
dos políticos em quem votamos tomar as
decisões certas
os nossos filhos nossos netos não vão
ter os problemas que a nossa geração
dele
obrigado
[Aplausos]